good morning it gets Friday I got up
around 8:00 went downstairs to pick up
the camera and then the Yeti and I drove
east past the kind of endless cornfields
that could make one wonder whether corn
monoculture might one day lead to a
zombie apocalypse and then we arrived in
knightstown Indiana we were there to
help two Swedish architects purchase a
tree which I realized sounds like code
for a drug deal or high-stakes
international diplomacy but yeah that's
the fascinating life of the museum
curators husband anyway I got bored
after a while I decided to walk across
the street to the huge Knights town
cemetery I love cemeteries for one thing
they contain a lot of names which is
very helpful for a writer
panitch a leisure and fred and blonde a
stickler and minnie hooker and mary
McFaul and ephraim Kahn fair and Walter
Mann love and wait so Carrie the founder
of Knights town I also love cemeteries
because they contain so many stories you
get to imagine the Union dead the first
marriage of Knights town and the more
you look the more narratives you find
coming out of tombstones there are the
straightforward ones like the sadness of
losing a child the amazingness of being
married for 61 years but also the
complicated ones like wait who is the
dude in that 61 year marriage vulva or
Mona were they night sounds first single
sex marriage probably not but I hope so
and while we're on the topic of stories
that get weirder the more you think
about them what's the deal with Walter
man loves wife nights down is a small
place and like a lot of towns in the
Midwest it's shrinking I drove over to
the downtown with its 57 Chevys and
old-fashioned ice cream joints and ducks
wearing headscarves Reds hot tanning in
a closed bookstore and a place called
bittersweet memories where I bought this
for Henry's room because it seems to me
like literally the best advice you can
give a child and also an adult it's easy
to feel nostalgic in night's town with
its paint chipped gazebo and I don't
believe in ghosts but that mansion is
definitely haunted mansions but nights
down has a present and a future as well
as its past which is something that
people tend to forget about small towns
in America someday that little girl will
decide if she wants to be part of this
town's future or if she wants to indulge
in the great American pastime of
lighting out for the territories but we
don't yet know what she'll decide or
what it'll mean for knightstown thinking
about that made me think about Walter
man love's wife Gussie she was 28 when
her husband died and I
imagine her picking out that headstone
committing right then and there to being
buried next to her husband but she
didn't yet know her future Hank maybe
she survived 113 and outlived the
century she'd committed herself to maybe
she forgot to pay for the plot next to
him or more likely maybe she had a life
that the 28 year old widow couldn't have
imagined maybe she married someone else
and built a life and although haunted by
her unkept promise to be buried with her
new spouse Hank I think that's why in
the end all we can really do is be kind
to each other we don't know what's ahead
for us or for our places after all think
nothing is etched in stone well until it
is I'll see you on Monday